le préfet du Loir-et-Cher a finalement
dit non au projet des pommero à cheval
entre Saint-Laurent-Nouan et la
Ferté-Saint-Cyr c'est à dire en pleine
Sologne il s'agissait de construire sur
500 hectares de forêts de terres
agricoles un vaste complexe touristique
plus de 500 maisons en bois un hôtel 4
étoiles un centre équestres un golf à la
clé la promesse de créer 200 emplois pas
suffisant pour convaincre les autorités
les défenseurs de l'environnement
Faustine Luneau
c'était sur ces terrains agricoles et
les zones boisées alentours que le
domaine des pommereaux devait voir le
jour impossible désormais puisque le
préfet du Loir-et-Cher a mis son veto
parmi les arguments avancés une
compensation insuffisante des zones
humides appelées à disparaître une
artificialisation des sols trop étendus
pour être en accord avec la loi climat
et résilience et la présence d'espèces
animales protégées
en fait on ne peut pas les détruire ou
détruire leur habitat sauf si on a
intérêt public majeur j'ai considéré que
la création d'un golf à proximité d'un
golf déjà existant et que la création de
200 emplois ne relevaient pas de
l'intérêt public majeur et j'ai rendu ma
décision sans passion et sans pression
c'est pas une décision politique le
dossier lourde de plus de 2000 pages
faisait parler de lui depuis de nombreux
mois alors cette décision était très
attendue par plusieurs associations et
groupes politiques locaux qui
critiquaient le projet depuis ses débuts
on est complètement évidemment
satisfaite ses décisions du préfet on
est très contents que ce projet ne soit
pas un intérêt public majeur pour lui on
ne peut participer des sols et
là c'était complètement contre projet
donc en fait on ne respecte pas la loi
en portant un tel projet donc c'était
tout à fait logique pour nous que le que
le préfet prenne cette décision décision
de bon sens décision qui va dans le sens
de l'évolution du dispositif législatif
mis en place pour préserver la planète
Europe Écologie Les Verts et Sologne
nature sauvage assure toutefois resté
vigilant car la société sanéo qui porte
le projet à la possibilité d'attaquer la
décision du préfet devant un tribunal
administratif contacter Bernard Saunier
le dirigeant de sanéo a refusé tout
commentaire